à tous hi mate un de ces fameux mot
intraduisible en langue française hi
mate est un mot allemand qui englobe
plusieurs notions et lorsque je les ai
entendu la première fois j'ai demandé
qu'est ce que cela voulait dire on m'a
tout simplement répondu hi mate c'est là
où l'on se sent chez soi
ok mais chez soi qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est la maison l'endroit où on a
grandi c'est peut-être plus que ça c'est
également un endroit qui nous évoque des
souvenirs chaleureux ou peut-être tout
simplement l'endroit où l'on sait où se
trouvent les couverts et le meilleur
café du quartier
et puis je me suis posé une question est
il possible d'avoir plusieurs hi mate
pour moi la réponse est évidemment oui
je fais partie de la grande famille des
expatriés j'ai vécu aujourd'hui cinq ans
à l'étranger
je parle de cet expert cette
expatriation qui vous concerne peut-être
une expatriation motivée par l' envie de
découverte de curiosité est
effectivement de mieux comprendre le
monde qui nous entoure et ainsi se mieux
se comprendre soi-même
bon je vous parle de ces endroits où de
cet étranger mais vous vous demandez
peut-être de quel endroit je parle alors
laissez moi vous présenter mes hi mate
tout d'abord voici dublin en irlande
j'ai effectué mon erasmus tu donc quatre
mois comme peut-être certains d'entre
vous ont déjà fait ou le feront dans les
années à venir
erasmus c'est la première expérience
d'expatriation et ça donne souvent le
goût du départ par la suite je suis
arrivé à hambourg une ville dans le nord
de l'allemagne
je suis d'abord allé pour un stage de
six mois et puis quatre ans après j
étais encore sans même m'en être rendu
compte
j'ai donc développer mon activité
professionnelle en tant que graphiste
freelance
j'ai rencontré des amis je me suis vue
créer un quotidien une vraie vie
d'expats voix et puis finalement en 2018
j'ai également eu l'envié de repartir
cette fois ci pour tokyo au japon dans
le cadre d'un visa de vacances travail
c'était un rêve de jeunesse enfin devenu
réalité
c'est trois lieux ces trois expériences
d'expatriation vous paraître ou
paraissent peut-être
différentes ces trois durées différentes
trois pays différents
trois langues différentes j'en passe des
différences et pour moi pourtant j'ai
réussi à faire de ces lieux mais ay
maths et j'aimerais donc vous raconter
qu est-ce qui fait pour moi se sentir
chez soi et comment j'ai pu le faire de
ces lieux des endroits où je me sens
bien et chez moi premièrement un des
premiers enjeux pour se sentir chez soi
il me semble que c'est la communication
on me demande demande d'ailleurs très
souvent est ce que tu parle allemand ou
japonais
avant de répondre à cette question je
dirai que avant mon départ je ne parlais
aucune des trois langues aux questions
bien entendu j'avais appris l'anglais à
l'école comme tout le monde mais
clairement je considérais pas que je
pouvais le parler et pourtant après
quatre mois d'erasmus j'avais la
capacité de discuter avec tous mes amis
espagnols italiens anglais et j'ai donc
développé mon internationale english que
j'utilise aujourd'hui tous les jours
pour ce qui est de l'allemand on dirait
que c'est la force des choses le fait de
passer du temps dans le pays
et puis finalement j'ai pris quelques
cours une fois sur place et je peux
communiquer dans la vie de tous les
jours pour le japonais c'est une autre
histoire nous dirons seulement que j'ai
un fort attrait pour la langue
attention je suis pas en train de dire
qu'il ne faut pas apprendre la langue du
pays dans laquelle on vit bien entendu
apprendre la langue c'est aussi se
donner l'opportunité d'avoir une
meilleure intégration de parler plus
facilement avec les locaux et puis on va
pas se mentir c'est quand même plus
pratique
je me souviens d'ailleurs qu'à mon
arrivée en allemagne j'ai dû faire
beaucoup de démarches administratives de
pour lesquelles je devais appeler au
téléphone et une conversation sur deux
se passer de la manière suivante
halloween should i go do you speak
english
autant dire que j'avais pas
d'information là et évidemment il ya
d'autres expériences qui sont beaucoup
plus positive
par exemple au japon je me suis acheté
un vélo et je me le suis fait voler au
bout de deux semaines quelque chose
comme ça oui ça existe aussi le vol au
japon et puis j'ai décidé d'aller au
commissariat pour faire un dépôt de
plainte de pertes et avoir la
possibilité de le retrouver car les
vélos sont immatriculés comme n'importe
quel autre véhicule à l'arrivée au
commissariat évidemment le policier ne
parlait pas un mot d'anglais et je
pouvais seulement dire duquesne chat
pour vélo mais finalement à force de
d'essayer de communiquer même si nous
parions pas la même langue
j'ai pu m'exprimer en mimant en faisant
un joli jeu de pikine harry puisque j'ai
quand même dessiné mon vélo avec les
couleurs ça et puis la personne en face
avait vraiment envie de m'aider et je
suis repartie victorieuse avec moi mon
dépôt de perte de ce vélo l'histoire
dira que je n'ai pas retrouvé mon vélo
mais ce qui était important pour moi
c'était de nous rendre compte que
j'avais la capacité de communiquer avec
ces gens sans même parler la même langue
et par extrapolation que la
communication n'était pas seulement une
histoire de langue mais aussi le désir
de deux personnes de voir un échange
être un succès
la langue doit être donc un outil mais
selon moi pas un frein à cette
communication
d'autant plus qu'il existe d'autres
problèmes pour que cette communication
soit efficace notamment les différences
culturelles en tant qu'expatrié on se
confronte tous les jours aux différences
culturelles
que ce soit pour dire bonjour ou et cela
crée des situations parfois drôles
parfois de surprises et parfois des
conflits lorsque j'ai mentionné le fait
de dire bonjour ça peut paraître simple
pour tout le monde mais cela peut créer
des situations totalement complexe et
qu'on ne s'y attend pas je me souviens à
l'arrivée en erasmus notamment j'ai fait
quelques soirées et avec un de mes amis
nous sommes rendus à une soirée en
question où il y avait beaucoup de monde
et beaucoup d'étrangers est mon ami
s'est présenté aux personnes
présente il a serré la main donc la
première personne qui était un homme
deuxième personne serrer la main et
arriver là la 3 à la quatrième personne
il s'est approché d'elle qu'il était une
donc une jeune fille pour le faire la
bise
elle était polonaise et n'était pas du
tout habitués à ce genre de pratiques
mon ami s'est approché et il n'a pas lu
sur son visage ce que j'ai ce dont j'ai
été témoin lc reculé et s'est figé de
peur à l'idée que cette personne
s'approche d'elle de cyprès pour ce qui
était mon ami un acte de politesse il
veut seulement dire bonjour a été
interprétée par elle part presque une
agression il ya donc un gap entre ces
deux sentiments et c'est la différence
culturelle qui crée ce gap pour éviter
ce genre de situation il faut bien
entendu comprendre demandé poser des
questions et toujours garder un certain
recul sur ce que l'on voit au jour le
jour et en même temps ces différences
culturelles bien sûr elle pose des
problèmes dans nos repères et les
repères c'est censé être des choses
importantes pour se sentir chez soi
mais est-ce que la différence culturelle
dans ce cas n'est pas le meilleur moyen
de remettre en question ses repères on
peut ensuite puisque on voit qu'il ya
d'autres manières de faire on peut enfin
se poser la question est ce que je fais
ça parce qu'on me l'a appris
où est ce que je fais ça parce que j'ai
envie de faire ça ou que ça fait sens
pour moi la différence culturelle je le
vois aussi que donc comment le un des
meilleurs moyens pour déconstruire ce
que l'on connaît et enfin se créer ses
propres repères qui font beaucoup de
blues de sens pour nous mêmes une fois
que l'on peut communiquer on peut enfin
faire des rencontres
ces rencontres qui sont essentiels pour
les expatriés étant donné que nous
vivons tous éloignés de nos familles
nous ne pouvons pas forcément rentrer
pour un anniversaire ou pour une soirée
juste prévenu la veille
bien entendu et c'est pour faire ces
rencontres cela peut paraître difficile
pour certaines personnes
lorsqu'on se déplace d'endroit en
endroit on perd nos amis et on doit
créer donc un nouveau de nouveaux liens
sociaux
personnellement j'ai découvert ainsi en
tant qu'expatrié la force des
communautés les communautés je parle des
communautés qui nous ressemblent de
personnes qui vivent les mêmes choses
comme les
communauté en erasmus la communauté des
français à l'étranger
et puis également des communautés de
gens qui s'intéressent aux mêmes choses
au même qui ont les mêmes activités
donc peut-être si on aime faire du ping
pong ou alors si on parle là une langue
commune ou qu'on essaie d'apprendre une
de ces langues et la force de ses
communautés c'est qu'aujourd'hui grâce
aux nouveaux outils numériques
on peut y accéder très facilement
notamment via les réseaux sociaux et les
réseaux sociaux ont donc été un outil
pour moi pour me faire de nouveaux amis
cela peut paraître une manière de
confronter de ne pas laisser place au
hasard mais du coup de chercher à se
faire des amis et pourtant des gens que
je rencontrais juste parce que j'avais
demandé de l'aide sur la création
d'entreprise en allemagne
ou peut-être parce que je vous laisse
totalement je voulais seulement
maintenant passer du temps et parler
peut-être une autre langue
ces personnes m'ont apporté bien plus
que ce que j'étais venu chercher
bien sûr au départ certaines m'ont
seulement fait découvrir d'autres
manières de penser et puis d'autres sont
devenus des amitiés très fidèle et j'ai
enfin créer mon cercle social
tout cela est possible parce que nous
avons également en tant que français un
privilège et c'est ce privilège dont je
voudrais vous parler également un
privilège que nous avons car en tant
qu'expatrié la définition même
d'expatriation c'est le fait de partir
volontairement de sa patrie et et l'on
sait bien que tout le monde ne peut pas
ne peut pas faire ça avec un passeport
français je peux vivre en europe sans
poser de questions
mon déménagement en allemagne il
suffisait que je rentre que je remplisse
quelques papiers mais je n'avais pas
besoin de demander d'autorisation ou de
visas particulier et puis cette notion
de privilège a été mise en avant surtout
par une expérience
une rencontre dont je veux que je vais
vous raconter quand j'habitais en
allemagne donc j'ai eu l'occasion de
participer à des activités avec des
enfants réfugiés des enfants qui du coup
était dans les camps de réfugiés et se
côtoyer mutuellement et j'ai rencontré
donc une petite fille qui est venue me
parler
elle venait d'afghanistan et elles
avaient entre huit et neuf ans
elle me parlait bien sûr dans un
allemand parfait et elle m'a demandé
d'où est ce que je venais j'ai répondu
donc frankreich avec montré fort accent
et puis elle m'a tout simplement demandé
à la suite de ça à et depuis quand
est-ce que tu as demandé l'asile
évidemment j'ai été un petit peu bouche
bée de cette question et puis je lui ai
juste dit ben en fait je n'ai pas
demandé l'asile puisque je suis venu par
de mon plein gré et cette jeune fille a
aussi été interloqué par ma réponse
puisqu'elle n'avait pas envisagé que
cela était possible que quelqu'un puisse
partir de son pays juste parce qu'il en
avait envie et finalement on avait il y
avait quelque chose qui nous séparait
énormément c'est le fait de pouvoir et
le fait d'être obligé d'être à un
endroit mais en y repensant nous avions
beaucoup de choses en commun avec cette
jeune fille elle avait dû se confronter
aux problèmes de communication apprendre
des langues
elle avait dû également se confronter au
problème de la différence culturelle et
enfin elle avait dû se créer des
nouveaux liens sociaux par dû à
l'éloignement avec sa famille tout comme
moi et c'est chose que j'ai en commun
avec cette jeune fille peut-être que je
les ai aussi en commun avec certains de
vous que ce soit parce que vous ayez
aussi vécu une expérience d'expatriation
ou parce que peut-être le fait de partir
de votre ville natale vous confronte
également à certaines de ses expériences
et finalement si nous avons toutes ces
choses en commun
je me demande si la question de que je
me suis posée à l'origine est ce qu'il
était possible d'avoir plusieurs hi mate
n'avait peut-être pas lieu d'être
puisque au final nous avons également
d'autres choses qui sont communes vous
comprenez peut-être de quel endroit je
parle mais laissez moi vous présenter
notre fine mat
merci
[Applaudissements]